اتواجد الان في محيط اكبر الله مراكز
التجاريه في قلب المدينه خيرسون هذا
المركز الذي تعرض للقصف كما تشاهدون هذه
شظايا القصف طالت الواجهه الاماميه للمركز
التجاري هنالك ايضا اثار لهذا القصف في
هذه
المنطقه وهنالك جثث ملقاه على الارض هذه
واحده من
الجثث قيل لنا بانه احد العمال في هذا
المركز التجاري هنالك جثه اخرى يستطيع
الزميل مصور احمد ان يقربها لكم هنا اثار
الدماء ما زالت اثار الدماء احمد اثار
الدماء في هذا المكان
هو هنا جثه اخرى ايضا سقطت في مدخل المجمع
التجاري الحديث عن سبعه قتلى حتى هذه
اللحظه بالاضافه الى عدد من الجرحى شظايا
الصواريخ في كل مكان هنالك
يمكن رصدها في كل مكان من هذا المجمع
التجاري السلطات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن قصف
متواصل تقوم به القوات الروسيه على طول
المراكز
الرئيسيه في المدينه والحديث عن
المجمعات التجمعات السكنيه في المقابل
تقول القوات الهكرانيه بان هنالك ضحايا
في غير مكان الحديث عن المناطق الواقعه
على طول خطا التماس والقوات الاوكرانيه
تقول بانها تكثف من قصفها بالمدفعيه
بالصواريخ براجمات الصواريخ على طول الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر دنيبر في المقاطعه وهي الضفه
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه الجزيره
خيرسون